I think today's testimony is among the
most significant evidence to date and
what we have just heard from ambassador
Sandlin is that the knowledge of this
scheme this conditioning of the White
House meeting of the security assistance
to get the deliverable the president one
of these two political investigations
that he believed would help his
reelection campaign was a basic quid pro
quo
it was the conditioning of official acts
for something of great value to the
president these political investigations
it goes right to the heart of the issue
of bribery as well as other potential
high crimes or misdemeanors but we also
have heard for the first time that
knowledge of this scheme was pervasive
the Secretary of State was aware of it
the acting chief of staff Albania was
aware of it and of course at the very
top Donald Trump through his personal
lawyer and others was implementing it
and so this I think only goes to
underscore just how significant the
president's obstruction of this
investigation has been we now can see
the veneer has been torn away just why
secretary Pompeo and President Donald
Trump do not want any of these documents
provided to Congress because apparently
they show as ambassador Solomon has
testified that the knowledge of this
scheme to condition official acts a
White House meeting and 400 million in
security assistance to an ally at war
with Russia was conditioned on political
favors the president wanted for his
so I think a very important moment in
the history of this
you